this footage shot by a tram enthusiast
gives you a drivers eye view of the
deadly Junction as the tram emerges from
the tunnel watch and listen as the
brakes are applied bringing the tram
speed right down to the designated 20
kilometers an hour limit
you can see the sign on the left of the
track
the Sandilands junction is negotiated
safely before the tram approaches the
station but on the morning of the 9th of
November it was a different story
with a devastating outcome an interim
report has found evidence the tram that
day was travelling much too fast the
findings have prompted calls for
automatic speed inhibitors to be fixed
to all trams but according to senior
crash investigators it's simply not
practical this is a tramway system and
the implementation of any new safety
system will be tight will take time and
needs to be considered and based on
solid evidence so no we cannot speculate
at this stage on the recommendations we
make but we give full consideration to
the design issues the tram set off just
before 6 o'clock in the morning from
Lloyd Park it was dark and raining
heavily going through the sand lands
tunnel the tram was traveling at 80
kilometers an hour well within the speed
limit however just before the curve at
the junction the speed limit drops to 20
kilometers an hour the tram dropped at
speed to just 70 kilometers an hour
still 3 times over the speed limit and
at 607 the tram derailed traveling 25
metres before it came to a stop
investigators so far have found no fault
in the track or mechanical failure of
the trams braking system but something
went seriously wrong leading to the
deaths of seven people one of the
important things that comes from the
report is that the signage was very
close to the actual bend itself I think
the report suggests is about 30 meters
or so in front of the bent it takes
something like under an 80 meter to stop
the train by the time it gets to that
sign so there's a clear need first of
all to improve the science so the
signage is further along the railway and
for the speed limit to be reduced much
further ahead as well the safety record
for trams is good but it's a relatively
new mass transport system commuters in
Croydon told us they have mixed feelings
about the network this is like a big
eye-opener for all drivers both tram
train buses that you need
be careful and a lot of lies are in your
hand the trams have got an excellent
history up to this point it seems like
an exceptional circumstance here it
hasn't rocked my confidence in them at
all really
the final report will take months to
complete investigators know what caused
the crash but desperately need to find
out why Ash's Joshi Sky News